thank you for joining us here on the
news at 4 I'm Shira matizawa and I'm
Doug pedcast we'll begin with a story
that's been developing all day police
say a man murdered his mother's killer
all in the span of 24 hours the two
related stabbings happened in Napa and
avamore now one man is in jail and two
people are dead yeah a lot of new
information coming in at the last minute
here NewsChannel 7's Jude Binkley joins
us now with what we know so far Jude
well sure just about an hour ago we got
a press release from Nampa PD about a
woman who was stabbed to death last
night at the 2100 block of West Grouse
Street in Napa this is a live look at
that area police say the suspect in that
stabbing is 39-year-old Jesus euretta
III of Nampa police say you read and
knew the woman and they were looking for
him overnight the Ada County Sheriff's
Office says A call came in just before
seven o'clock this morning deputies were
directed to the Mobile gas station
parking lot near the entrance to the
avamor community where they found a man
dead inside a car they found the victim
slumped over with a stab wound inside of
a running parked car paramedics
performed first aid and took the man to
a local hospital where he was pronounced
dead that man was euretta and the
suspect the suspect in last night's
Nampa murder I should say investigators
taped off the gas station and on the
other side of crime scene tape there was
this dark blue Buick Regal with front
fender and Tire Damage deputies set up a
tent beside the car deputies arrested
31-year-old Raul Alexander Cuevas after
they found him in a car at this Chevron
gas station about five miles down
Highway 55 off of Beacon Light Road they
took him into custody after talking to
him similar scenes at the two gas
stations the crime scene tape at the
Chevron gas station blocked off parts of
it and surrounded a silver Kia now
Cuevas is being held in the Ada County
Jail on a first degree murder charge now
the woman who was killed in Nampa was 52
year old Michelle Luna who was cuevas's
Mother the case is still under
investigation to make the long story
short it's a man killed a woman the
woman's son killed the man who killed
her
that's the gist of it
and he's being charged with first-degree
murder was he right doing that I don't
think so do I understand
yeah
I get it
I'm actually curious to you guys if you
guys find out your mom gets murked let's
say you had a good relationship with her
okay you didn't hate her she wasn't some
person who abandoned you hypothetical
okay
she gets murked by some dude
and you're alone in a room with him and
you got a weapon
you gonna stop yourself
you can actually honestly there's no
right or wrong answer I'm just curious
I would say that for me too it would be
incredibly hard to know that somebody
robbed me of my mother
and I had an opportunity
now of course
the issues with these kinds of actions
is that the law it's not just the law
this presumes the guilt of the person
who did it to the mother yeah what if
you get the wrong person this is the
problem of vigilance and Justice right
this is fine for a lot of people because
he got the right person but sometimes
they get the wrong person and an inner
person innocent person dies because
someone's wrath yeah unless unless you
were there when that should happen yeah
yeah but even yeah in the perfect
scenario where you got the right person
you've seen them do it like yeah I I
ain't even mad at you and the reason why
I got first degree is because he planned
it obviously found out the information
got the weapon drove there there's
plenty of time that's what makes it
premeditated is that he thought
beforehand he had a lot of time to think
about what he did 24 hours a long time
and he succeeded he thought about it do
I understand it hell yeah hell [__]
yeah hell yeah I mean bro Hey listen
listen I ain't nothing to do with like
you you brought me one of the most
precious people in my life the one who
I'd give everything for like yeah I
could understand the sentiment I wanted
to die for that I know it's 100 wrong
but Jesus it's not 100 wrong actually
okay oh hold on hold on let me let me
it's great
let me rephrase that because you're
right it's not morally right
oh into the confinement of the Law
whatever I like I understand why I
shouldn't do that [__] until my mama
would want me to do that no she wouldn't
actually I think my mama would be like
get that [__] uh
you think so my mama is I've seen you
she going to jail
you know
I'm curious
let me call my mama right now
I'm actually curious I I think I know
the answer
I think that
hello hello so I didn't did this
issues hidden situation okay reality
okay
foreign
[Music]
no
no no no
no okay
um
[Laughter]
it is
she perfect perfect answer no thank you
Hey listen if I die it's my time
but you said Allah will get them yeah
don't ever understand that's what I
understood
I got that hey I got that
unless you went to family examples
remember that person yeah
well well God gonna cover them I think
God also gave me you I was like okay
that's a pretty good compliment you know
I'll take that let me have them all she
said yo will Revenge bring me back
I said no she's like no that's fine
if I die was my time and Allah I'll give
you what he deserves
hey man if you if you like my mom's
comments you would leave a like in the
comments below
oh got fat
one about you
um
foreign
way
s here
Oh my days
foreign
being religious like your mom is
religiously I think most of it is just
you're a parent you don't want your
child to suffer you've already gone yeah
you know I mean like you just don't want
your kid to have to suffer afterwards so
would you want would you want the kid to
be like no of course not of course not
this is not even the answer to me that
would want that the idea of my kids
suffering the rest of their life in jail
and suffering every day would make me so
[__] sad
you'd want that no of course not I mean
when you look at the camera smiling
though I know I know oh I got him his
shot bruh I'm just playing I'm just
playing gotcha gotcha yeah for anybody
it's funny how we think that you know I
mean like for a second I I think I'm
doing it right yeah but you understand
that she wouldn't want that for your son
for your son or your daughter or
whatever or not yeah but you would think
about it well you you just you think
about the pain and the absence of the
person to hurt you want to think of some
way to remedy that or feel that voice
yeah and you think doing this will fix
that but at the end of the day like you
still gonna have to live with their
absence for the rest of your life you
think you've made it right because like
that's what we also think about like
retribution don't get me wrong Revenge
can feel pretty good in the moment it
can feel a little bit good afterwards
but over time it still doesn't fix the
problems that you've had so you're still
left with a bigger deficit so like the
decisions that we have in place are the
right ones they don't always work but
they are the right ones
now this [__] got off scot-free
I'm hiring a hit man I'm saving my money
and I'm hiring somebody and they marking
his ass if you got a scot-free
I would do it super covert so nobody
comes back to me I would watch the trial
go and if he gets off scot-free and like
we know it's him but he got off on some
technicality
you gotta go that's me person I would
have a hard time existing in the world
the same man who murdered my and could
walk around free I don't think I could
handle that I don't think I could handle
that if the justice system failed me
even though it was wrong I think I would
probably do that even if my mom wouldn't
want to
that's me maybe that's too far for some
people I'm not mad at that's just I
couldn't imagine
yeah so that's my thoughts anything else
hey you go ahead and self snitch I ain't
saying [__] about that all right listen
you can say whatever they want they
can't find any proof it don't matter
what I say on video Charleston white no
but they could
it was right anyways let us know what
you guys it's not right it's white